after a decade of bitter rivalry
their first meeting was an icebreaker
both leaders smiled to the cameras then
president allah invited his predecessor
into a palace he was forced to leave ten
years ago
at the end of the meeting that lasted an
hour the two leaders came out relaxed
and with words of hope for a deeply
divided nation
now the meeting we've been eagerly
waiting for has happened we should all
congratulate each other
there's been crises and divisions in our
country but that's all behind us
the most important thing is peace for
our country as lawrence said
it is important for us to move forward
it's good for our future
on his part lauren bagbo asked that
ivorians jailed for their roles in the
country's political crisis
be set free
i'm very happy with our meeting because
it was very relaxed and i'm very proud
about it
and i requested that we should have such
discussions from time to time
to reduce the tension in the country the
power test between the two foes sparked
two civil wars that cost thousands of
lives
and the country's political stability
bhagava who still commands a large
following despite his 10-year absence
from ivory coast
is key to its future stability so also
other exiled politicians
like former speaker of parliament
guillaume soro once
our terror ally the meeting is seen as
an important first step
i think they realize that it's time to
figure out the future we cannot face
what's not what we saw in 2011.
but some ivorians are skeptical of a
quick reconciliation
these victims and families of those
killed during the country's wars
gathered to lay a wreath hours before
the meeting
if they want to reconcile they can but
that should come at the expense of the
victims of their political rivalry
if victims are not involved and are not
happy they might as well expel us from
the country
ten years of national reconciliation
driven mainly by civil society
has so far failed to heal wounds here
one meeting
won't immediately change that
al jazeera